all right let's make a cooking video
today so today we are going to make
jambalaya jambalaya is one of my
favorite dishes because kind of like how
fried rice is for Asians it's a kind of
like a white people's fried rice you can
put anything you want in it it's super
flexible in terms of the recipes
obviously there's going to be
traditional jambalaya but it's just
welcomed so many different flavors
different variations create a totally
different experience and that's what I
love about jambalaya that's where we're
gonna make today I'm going to show you
how I make from Malaya alright so first
things first let's introduce the players
just to give you guys a shopping list
here we go it's a long one we need three
strips of bacon one medium onion two
bell peppers for celery stalks five
garlic cloves some parsley several
stalks of green onions two cups of white
rice for andouille sausages two
tablespoons of tomato paste one can of
diced tomatoes 2 cups of seafood stock
and the ultimate all star of this dish a
pound of shrimp now when we bind the
shrimp by whole shrimps with the head
attached to it still because we're going
to make our own homemade seafood stock
and in order to do that we're going to
need some shrimp heads now we're
definitely overachieving with this dish
technically you could use chicken stock
you can use beef broth you can use
vegetable stock if you want doesn't
matter I personally really like
jambalaya with a hint of seafood flavors
and so I'm gonna utilize the flavors of
shrimp and crab to make the ultimate
jambalaya so first things first let's
start with the shrimp after rinsing the
shrimp you're gonna want to decel and
also behead no the head no just take
away the head from the body of the
shrimp
once you do shell and get rid of the
head we're gonna keep the shrimp and
we're gonna put it away in their fridge
because we're gonna utilize that at the
end of the recipe now for the seafood
stock take a pot put some olive oil into
it and toss your shrimp heads into there
you're going to sauté the shrimp heads
for about a minute or two just until the
shrimp heads get pink and you're going
to instantly smell the flavors of the
shrimp now with shrimp and seafood in
general the majority of the fat aka the
flavor is going to come from the actual
the head of the of the shrimp that's
where like all this stuff is that now I
know what you're thinking it might be
kind of gross but this is how it's done
so you're going to sauté the shrimp it's
gonna bring out the flavors introduce
the crab to it now for you guys that
don't want to deal with making your own
seafood stock that's fine
stick with the chicken stock or a beef
stock it all works out you can use water
if you want but I don't I don't
recommend that once you have two shrimp
in the crab cooking for about two
minutes you want to introduce your
chicken broth to the concoction-- place
it on high bring it up to a boil I want
to make this stock a little sweet in
terms of the aroma in order to do that
I'm gonna add some of those carrots that
we have just coarsely chopped there
we're not eating the carrot so it's just
for flavoring chop it up
we're in toss it into the stock once
it's boiling you want to reduce the heat
bring it back down to the simmer and let
that sit for the next two hours while
you prep your jambalaya we got to
introduce a little bit of fat like I
said that is flavor
so let's start off with the bacon three
strips of bacon you can actually use six
strips of bacon if you want I personally
would use six strips but I'm trying to
I'm trying to stay lean so I'm not gonna
go too crazy with the bacon you're gonna
want to cut the bacon into like one-inch
little squares I guess toss into that
new pot and let that sizzle and let that
cook and let that Brown you want to
start your jambalaya with some nice
bacon fat some nice bacon flavor now
while that's browning and we're sweating
the crap out of the bacon start off with
the onion and let's chop that up now I
got to introduce you to the Holy Trinity
now the Holy Trinity is the base for a
lot of regional
is from Louisiana your Holy Trinity is
going to consist onion bell peppers and
celery that's exactly what we're going
to add next dice it up nice even pieces
you don't want certain pieces larger
than others because you want to make
every bite of jambalaya uniform in your
mouth it's all about proportion and
flavors with this dish and that makes a
perfect bite I'm using about double the
amount of vegetables that you're going
to see in most jambalaya dishes just
because I love vegetables in my opinion
the more the merrier and it's just going
to make your jambalaya that much more of
a slam-dunk of flavors now when it comes
to rice we're gonna need two cups of
rice white rice make sure you wash your
rice we want to get rid of that starchy
how do we layer that's on the outside of
the grain or else your your rice is
going to start clumping together and get
too starchy once you're done with that
toss that into the pot and you want to
toast the rice from that point on and
start introducing those flavors coming
from the Holy Trinity and from the bacon
and start infusing those flavors into
the grains of rice you want to make sure
that you keep stirring this the rice is
going to start sticking to the bottom if
it sticks to the bottom you're gonna
have really burnt up rice at the bottom
of your pot and it's gonna be hard to
wash now while the rice is toasting
we're gonna introduce the rest of the
vegetables so we're gonna take the four
to six garlic cloves that we have you're
going to dice that up as well toss that
in take some parsley just a nice handful
of parsley and dice that up into nice
little shreds and sprinkle that in last
but not least the green onions now once
you have the green onions chopped up you
want to use about 3/4 of that 75% of the
green onions goes into the pot and at
this point you're going to start
smelling all those aromatics all those
vegetables kind of just fusing together
and creating this beautiful flavor this
beautiful aroma from here we're gonna
start introducing our proteins so we're
gonna take this for andouille sausages
once again we're going to just cut them
up into nice little coins about a
quarter of an inch thick and dice those
up and you know toss them and just like
everything else
now these end dewey sausages they're of
french origin it is a smoked pork
sausage so once you have the andouille
sausages give it a 1 nice stir really
dig into the bottom and really get all
the bottom stuff up
you don't want it to burn smoke flavor
for then do we sausages is one thing
burnt flavor from the rice getting stuck
at the bottom that's a whole nother
thing we do not want that our jumbo is
looking really really really green which
is great but now we're gonna add the
color of passion to it some Reds so
we're going to start introducing our
tomatoes let's go ahead and add our 1
can of tomatoes and 2 tablespoons of
tomato paste once we have the tomatoes
add it in our seafood stock should be
done or right about now should be about
one or two hours so we're gonna go ahead
and extract 2 cups a seafood stock now
this can't be kind of tricky jambalaya
is one of those dishes you can easily
add too much liquids to and it's going
to turn into this mushy gushy kind of
texture where the rice grains are
completely gone we don't want that since
we added so many vegetables there's
actually quite a bit of liquid and
moisture coming from the vegetables
still and along with those tomatoes that
we just added there's plenty of liquid
to go around so we don't want to drown
our rice with too much of this stock
that we made a little bit goes a long
way so we're going to only use 2 cups of
the seafood stock and once you've added
your liquids the next thing you want to
do is add some spices and some salt and
pepper to taste now I usually like to
throw in some paprika for some color and
then I usually like to also add some
oregano flakes as well just to kind of
give it that extra complexity of flavors
and we're gonna bring that up to a boil
and once at a boil I usually like to
give it one last stir just so that you
pick up all the bottom stuff up just to
keep it moving and never let it settle
for too long or else it's gonna burn now
once you give it a nice stir we're gonna
finally place the lid on top up into
this point we haven't touched the lid
it's been open this is the time when we
put the lid on we're gonna trap all that
heat and moisture in there and really
let those flavors now to really really
let it cook into the rice and let the
rice start to soak in all the flavors
now to its very very core now you're
gonna want to cook your rest for about
30 minutes you used to remember the
shrimp that we had from the beginning of
the cook let's get those out again now
while the rice is cooking I usually like
to take this time to cut the shrimp's in
half we're into thirds depending on the
size of the shrimp and since we're
waiting for 30 minutes I'm
take this time to also devein the shrimp
so now take the lid off you're going to
see this amazing looking jambalaya it's
going to start taking shape now take the
shrimp we're going to dump the shrimp in
as soon as the shrimp goes in we take
off the heat turn off your stove we're
going to be using the residual heat in
the pot to finish up our jambalaya the
easiest mistake to make at this point is
to stir the shrimp in you don't want to
stir the rice at this point is going to
be very very soft and tender and the
more you stir the more of the rice grain
itself is going to start breaking and
once it starts breaking with all that
moisture and liquid in there it's going
to start turning into a mush and you
definitely do not want that so when you
add your shrimp in what you want to do
is take a ladle and actually dig deep to
the bottom and bring it back up dig to
the bottom bring it back up
he's very gentle with the rice and kind
of let the rice smother the shrimp and
let that residual heat cook the shrimp
remember those remaining green onions
that we chopped up and spring those back
out and we're going to just kind of
sprinkle them into the pot and let those
green onions kind of state you don't
want to cook those green onions too much
so once again we're also using the
residual heat from the pot to get those
green onions worked into the rest of the
jambalaya and then once you have that
done there's only one thing left to do
the most beautiful ingredient that we're
going to introduce the pot is butter
we're going to use about two tablespoons
of butter I know I said I'm on a diet I
didn't want to use too much bacon but at
the end of the day that butter just
really kind of just brings everything
together it just makes it very cohesive
it's just a nice little coating of
butter that creaminess gently work that
into the rest of the jambalaya and make
sure it coats as many grains of rice as
possible and just kind of keep it moving
for a little bit for you very very
gentle voila we have jambalaya
the best jambalaya you're ever gonna
taste good mmm is good
I surprised myself they're eating my
food it's yummy mm-hmm I like this lazy
seasoning don't start with me and
they're having a very good meal beat it
No